the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences is under fire from the race
focus left for once again snubbing
performers of color any Oscar
nominations but in the Academy's defense
there will at least be more black
candidates in the running at the Oscars
then there will be a tonight's all-white
Democratic presidential debate in Des
Moines Iowa we will examine the
incoherence and hypocrisy of racial
identity politics then Bernie Sanders
says a woman can't win in 2020 according
to a new report from CNN and the Warren
campaign we will revel in the circular
firing squad all that and so much more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
we've got some breaking news another one
bites the dust Cory Booker has dropped
out of the presidential race
now Eric's whoa well who is me dropped
out of the presidential race six months
ago but Spartacus who I am
dropped out yesterday which means that
by the rule of double negation I think
that I am still in it however Cory
Booker is no longer in it and so we bid
him farewell in memoriam I knowingly
violated the rules that were put for and
I understand that that the penalty comes
with potential outs ting from the Senate
I hope that they will bring charges
against us this is about the closest
I'll probably ever have in my life to an
I am Spartacus moment this toxic culture
this pernicious patriarchy in this
country has to stop I hurt I had tears
of rage and for you not to feel that
pain hurt and that pain that's
unacceptable to me I heard I have tears
of rage I feel that pain that Cory
Booker is at we knew we knew when who
leon castro dropped out it was only a
matter of days maybe weeks probably days
until the next woke Ascan 'added cory
booker dropped out of the race but i
feel that pain i feel those tears of
rage Booker's numbers have been pretty
low pretty much non-existent for a while
a president Trump found this out
yesterday her he acknowledged this
yesterday when he tweeted at something I
have been hoping he would tweet for
every single candidate who drops out
which is every time like when Kirsten
Gillibrand dropped out he said oh no
Kirsten Gillibrand is gone she is the
one I was really worried about and then
Cory Booker dropped out he goes Cory
Booker whose poll numbers have been zero
for months is dropped out but he was the
one I was so scared of going up against
I really want him to do that with every
candidate who drops out but the writings
been on the wall for Booker for a long
time actually here is Cory Booker
explaining what this race has meant to
him as he exits what it means to get out
of the
way for a stronger candidate to win the
nomination and take on the president in
November la situación our order is
inacceptable es de presidente attack
Tavo de mon asado los FEMA grant is
inacceptable a voyeur can be arrested
now I have no idea if if that's what
that means in Spanish at all but in my
defense
neither does cory booker so he is gone
and the democrats have now successfully
kicked out all of the candidates who are
not translucent which is how we're going
to get an all-white democratic debate
tonight in des moines gonna be very
interesting for them to peddle racial
politics when all of them are as white
as anybody I've ever met we will get to
the Democrats so white we will get to
the Oscars so white we will get to why
the libs generally speaking are just so
white but first I've got to save you
money
you shop online everybody shops online
right you are almost certainly
overpaying I have been using honey since
before my show existed since before the
Daily wire existed honey
saves you money period it's it saves you
money at over 30,000 stores online
including Macy's Target Sephora Best Buy
on and on and on and they're adding more
stores every single day it's found it's
over 18 million members over two billion
dollars in savings how do you do it it's
a little browser extension it takes two
clicks you add it on and then as you're
shopping it just shows you automatically
it shows you the money that you could
save I was what was I just buying I was
just I was just buying three new shirts
three new just regular white shirts
right this should be the simplest thing
to buy and yet I nearly spend an extra
twenty five dollars on these shirts if I
didn't have honey I go out check out my
little honey extension all of a sudden I
save that money automatic using honey
feels great think of it as just a little
daily victory a little little pep in
your step
plus it's free to use it installs in
just a few seconds get honey for free it
join honey calm slash Knowles Cana wles
I can't tell you how much money I've
saved over the years with honey that's
join honey dot-com
/ Knowles kami WL e s the Dems are so
white remember a few years ago why she
they've been doing it every year since
then there was a hashtag going around
the internet
hashtag Oscars so white because they
snubbed some black candidates as they
did again this year hashtag Dems so
white
we know it you know when you think of
the 2016 Republican field there were a
lot of candidates of a lot of different
races who lasted pretty long right you
had Ben Carson he's racial minorities
black you had Marco Rubio he's Hispanic
you had Ted Cruz Ted Cruz made it almost
until the very end he was the last guy
standing other than Donald Trump so the
Republicans who don't talk and boast and
brag about all their racial diversity
and how much more virtuous they are than
Democrats they don't constantly malign
Democrats as a bunch of racial bigots
like the Democrats do to us they had a
ton of racial diversity right until the
very end
Democrats kicked out all the candidates
who aren't lily-white before 2020 even
began right before the first Democratic
presidential debate of 2020 all of their
non-white candidates are gone this is a
real problem for Democrats right they
make multiculturalism they make racial
identity politics the central point of
their political pitch they call
everybody else racist and then steadily
from the very beginning of this race
they've kicked out every minority
candidate and by the way every time they
do it they lament the awful racism of
kicking out these candidates Kamala
Harris Kamala Harris didn't lose because
she's just a terrible retail politician
no they couldn't say that she lost
because she's black and a woman and so
they'll add gender politics in there -
well guys you're the ones voting so
maybe it's your fault maybe take a look
at the man in the mirror if you really
believe that that's the reason that she
and Castro and Booker and these other
candidates have dropped out this is not
merely a case of Democrats failing to
live up to their ideals because you
might say well well Michael at least the
Democrats prioritize race
politics they might not live up to
actually voting for the candidates who
are racial minorities but at least they
think about it it's at the top of mind
you know there's a line that I like to
quote from LaRoche Foucault which is
that hypocrisy is the tribute that vice
pays to virtue at least Democrats have a
standard on racial diversity Republicans
don't even have a standard you might say
I don't think so I think that's a pretty
bad analogy right you you saw this a
little bit with the porn debate remember
at the end of 2019 all these
conservatives were debating whether we
should regulate porn or ban porn or have
porn everywhere and the the hypocrite
argument is you've got all these
conservatives who want to ban porn but a
lot of them look at porn all the time
right that's a case of hypocrisy as the
tribute vice pays to virtue because
they're admitting a moral standard and
they're failing to live up to it right
these conservatives will say I hate porn
I think it's terrible it's bad for your
brain it's bad for your soul it's
objectifies women right it's it's
misogynistic and yet many men in this
country the majority men in this country
have a compulsion or an addiction to
look at these kind of materials so they
really try not to they try to resist but
the temptation overcomes them and
sometimes they look at naked ladies on
the Internet
that is not the case with Democrats in
racial politics it's not like they're
really trying to vote for Kamala Harris
and they just can't pull the lever for
some reason they really want to vote for
Cory Booker but when the pollster calls
them on the phone they say no I prefer
people to judge there's no impediment to
them supporting these candidates and how
about the candidates themselves if these
candidates these liberals really believe
that white people have ruined everything
and we need to choose candidates of
other races now and that's that should
be the first thing we think about in
politics then drop out Budaj edge Biden
Bernie Warren if you really believe that
if you actually believe this is a
terribly racially bigoted country and
white people have had seats in the
Senate for too long and they've been
running for president for too long we
got to get the white people out and get
other races in okay lead the way do it
drop out Barack Obama said this a couple
months ago he was making some pain
during ridiculous remark where he said
that men have ruined everything in
politics and if the world were run by
women everything would be so much better
he doesn't believe that you know how I
know he doesn't believe that because he
was elected president in 2008 by beating
Hillary Clinton if he really believed
that women are so much better than men
and men of ruined society and women
should take the lead in politics he
wouldn't have run in 2008 if he had run
because he didn't know Hillary was gonna
run he would have dropped out and
endorsed her but he didn't instead he
dragged that campaign out and got into a
pretty vicious campaign with Hillary
Clinton and absolutely pummeled her
political career into obscurity that was
it right and then he became president
for eight years they don't really
believe this they don't really believe
that we should give racial minority
candidates and female candidates special
treatment by the way I don't think we
should give them special treatment
either I think that we should judge
candidates on their accomplishments and
on their character and on their
platforms what they're gonna do and
whether they can actually do what they
say they're gonna do and we should judge
them on electability you got to pick a
winner it doesn't matter if you've got
the most wonderful candidate in the
world if the guy can't get elected or
the girl can't get elected then they're
no good to you
right the winners go and make laws and
the losers go home as Mitch McConnell
once said clearly the Democrats feel the
same way of course they feel the same
way that's what politics is but the
Democrats won't admit it they are living
in Lies they are lying to themselves
they are lying about themselves and they
are lying about their opponents that's
just the way it is there all we have to
all sit here in the democratic debate
tonight I'm sure they're gonna bring it
up and they're gonna lament that there
were no racial minorities on stage
nobody cares nobody was supporting these
candidates right it's not this is not an
example of structural racism or
structural sexism or something like that
they just didn't get poll numbers they
just didn't get any donations because
nobody wants them because they're weak
Canada
and the trouble is that the candidates
left on stage although all the white
candidates are pretty weak as well we're
gonna see that whittled down as it goes
it's not just in the presidential race
it's also in Hollywood
you got the Democratic candidates so
white you've got the Oscars so white
because despite lip service to the
contrary the Oscars are white and male
as well there was only one black former
nominated in a major category that is
Cynthia areevo as Harriet Tubman and
actually some people were upset about
this they were upset that the nomination
for the black actress was for this role
of a sort of historical legendary
larger-than-life black figure a slave an
ex-slave who helps other slaves escape I
don't really understand how people are
upset about this love it
this actress was not gonna play Jackie
Kennedy right there was gonna if you
were talking about historical figures
then you're gonna talk about the
historical figures that the actors or
actresses look more like now it is true
the look I'll never defend Hollywood
Hollywood doesn't make a lot of roles
for racial minorities that's why on
average you'll notice this in films on
average the performance by black actors
and actresses is better than the average
performance by white actors and
actresses because there just aren't that
many roles so generally speaking the the
people who get those roles are just
really really good performers but the
issue here for the for the Academy for
the left for the woke people who are
really upset about the Oscars so white
is is not quality its quantity they're
upset that more people were not
nominated they're upset that there
aren't more you know half of the
nominees and Best Actor Best Picture
Best Director or in this race or that
race or this sex you know they're
they're upset that Greta Gerwig who is a
very good director was not nominated for
Best Director I didn't see the movie she
made she made a little women I think and
I I was not particularly compelled to go
see that I'll leave that to sweet little
Elise if she wants to I don't think she
was
what's interesting in all of the
coverage about how the Oscars are so
racist in the Academy is so racist is
parasite which is a Korean movie
actually was nominated for a bunch of
Awards it was nominated for Best Picture
it was nominated for Best Director but
according to the woke crowd these racial
politics people Asians don't count as
real minorities I guess because they
were saying nope they're sort of white
uh-uh
that doesn't count it's got to be
different it's got to be our preferred
races not not other racial minorities as
a whole I haven't seen most of the
movies so I can't really comment on the
justice or the injustice of the
nominations but I actually would like to
say something nice about Hollywood and
liberals on the issue of racial politics
I actually would like to take the
temperature down in the country a little
bit bring together a little bit of
political unity it kills me to do it but
I'm gonna say something nice about
Hollywood and about the Democratic
candidates in just one second first I've
got to thank our friends over at
NetSuite a major problem
for growing businesses maybe the biggest
problem that keeps them from growing it
keeps them from getting a handle on
their business is they don't know their
numbers they don't know they've got all
these different business systems so
they've got one system for accounting
one system for sales one system for
inventory on and on and on why does that
happen
because when you're starting a business
you use what you know you use what's
easiest you use what the employee that
you hired knows those systems aren't
talking to each other you don't know
your numbers this can be a big deal not
just waste of time not just a waste of
money not just a bunch of headaches
it can imperil your business you're
gonna lose your business before you even
know it's in trouble that it can really
hurt the bottom line introducing that
suite by Oracle the business management
software that handles every aspect of
your business and an easy-to-use cloud
platform giving you the visibility and
control that you need to grow NetSuite
is the world's number one cloud business
system you can manage sales finance
accounting orders HR all instantly right
from your desktop or phone right now
NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a three guides seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Knowles Canada
ul es that is NetSuite comm / Knowles K
no W l es download your free guide do it
right now seven key strategies to grow
your profits
NetSuite comm slash Knowles I would like
to say something nice and fair and not
just take cheap shots at Hollywood and
the left and the Democratic candidates
they would never be fair with us I would
like to be fair with them I don't think
that Democratic primary voters hate
black people I don't think that the
Academy hates black people or Hispanic
people or other racial minorities I
think sometimes black performers win the
Oscars like Denzel Washington or Halle
Berry or Jamie Foxx and I think
sometimes performers of other races when
the Oscars I think sometimes women win
Best Director there was that woman who
actually the only woman who's won a
Kathryn Bigelow but more often men win
Best Director because there were many
many many more male directors than
female directors not because there's
some law against female directors just
the way it is sometimes the black
presidential candidate wins like last
time like actually our last president
sometimes the orange presidential
candidate wins like okay I think our
current president in order for the
typical leftist charge to be true half
of this country the conservative half
the right half the Republican half has
to be racist and sexist and terrible and
bigoted and deplorable and irredeemable
if though if the typical leftist charge
is true a full half of the country
hundred fifty million people are just
hate-filled bigots but now in order for
the woke left discharge to be true the
Oscars so white crowd the Democrat
candidates so why crowded for their
charge to be true the whole country has
to be bigoted and sexist and racist and
terrible and hate black
people in hate Hispanics and be
motivated by just pure bile and vitriol
does anybody think that that's true I
guess the really hardened left thinks
that because they're really hardened
left hates the country right the really
hardened radical left hates the founding
of the country hates the history of the
country hates the traditions of the
country hates the present state of the
country believes that the present state
of our society and government and
politics is literally violent to many
people and so they want to completely
get rid of it and progress forward they
want something new they think that the
only thing holding us back
are these vestigial remnants of the
American Founding in a minute we get rid
of those we can move on to utopia that's
true of the very very hard and left
everybody else though I don't think we
really believe that all of our
countrymen are terrible bigots I
certainly don't we are the least
racially divisive country on earth we're
pretty much the only country on earth
where you can't be a racist right you
can go to go to Europe go to Asia go to
India go anywhere else in the world
people are much much more conscious of
race and much more divided on race than
we are in the United States that's a
lovely thing we should be happy about
that
we should say hey good job everybody
good job America we're but that's not
what the very very hard left wants to do
and it's easy to take some some shots at
Democrats and the left for their racial
hypocrisy and I'm more than happy to do
it because they need to be called out on
their hypocrisy on this issue and many
others but it's not because I want to
accuse them and make them feel terrible
and have them admit they're all terrible
racists I want them to admit that we're
doing fine we're doing just fine we have
a VIP we have relatively excellent
racial relations in the country
obviously we have wonderful gender
relations you know they say that we'll
will never have a gender war because
everybody's sleeping with the enemy so
I'm not terribly confused about that
rather
because things things seem to be going
fine on that front as well until the
left admits it until the left admits
things are looking pretty good in the
country till the left admits that the
country that they say is hopelessly
bigoted elected a black guy last time
until they admit that the Academy has
given plenty of words to racial
minorities and plenty of awards to women
and if they want more than okay that's
fine I mean that's Hollywood they can
deal with Hollywood but until they admit
that this isn't some just totally closed
off country the patriarchy the white
supremacy or whatever slogans and bumper
stickers they're gonna use until they
admit that we are going to point out
their hypocrisy and we are going to
laugh and enjoy and lap up the circular
firing squad because there is no sign
that the left is going to cut it out
instead they are ratcheting it up
they're turning it all the way up to 11
just to give you a little appetizer a
little amuse-bouche for tonight's
democratic debate in Des Moines
Elizabeth Warren is now personally
insinuating that Bernie Sanders is some
kind of male chauvinist a sexist this
leaked yesterday to CNN there was a leak
certainly from the Elizabeth Warren camp
that during a private meeting in 2018
between Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders where they were gonna try to
negotiate and hash out how they were
both gonna run for president Bernie
Sanders that misogynist that sexist told
Elizabeth laia waffle Warren that a
woman can't win in 2020 bum-bum-bum this
was leaked to CNN from anonymous sources
namely Elizabeth Warren and people close
to her and then when the story wasn't
gaining a ton of traction Warren doubled
down on it herself she came in she said
I thought a woman could win he disagreed
I have no interest in discussing this
private meeting any further because
Bernie and I have far more in common
than our differences in punditry
I think you do have an interest in
discussing this further I think that's
why you leaked it
classic Elizabeth Warren is so
disingenuous all of these candidates are
so disingenuous I'm trying to think of
an earnest candidate maybe a Klobuchar
Klobuchar might be the closest thing we
have to an earnest candidate and she's
completely unimpressive as a retail
politician so she's not going anywhere
but I think yeah Klobuchar
Tulsi yang those are kind of the earnest
honest candidates the rest of them are
just total empty shills well in terms of
the major candidates I guess there's a
little exception for Bernie and that is
why Elizabeth Warren is so upset
because Elizabeth Warren was gonna be
the progressive standard-bearer she was
gonna take over that wing of the party
because it's her time she's young
relatively she's not no spring chicken
but she's young in this field where the
median age is 162 she's a woman she's at
various times a Native American not not
actually but according to her Harvard
biography she is when it suits her to
try to get a better job in the Academy
she's a Native American and hey she
might be one 1024 Native Americans so
give her the benefit of the doubt she
was supposed to take the progressive
line and Bernie is surging and her
campaign is collapsing her campaign is
collapsing for a couple of reasons one
it's disingenuous people see her as a
kind of Harvard establishment Arian
maybe she's a left winger in the way
that intellectuals are left wingers
right they're left wingers while they
write their books and they can be really
radical and they can be really violent
but they don't have the cred they
haven't been out there marching in the
streets all right Elizabeth Warren has
never tasted a beer in her life until
she did that video with her husband so
they're skeptical of that and they're
skeptical of her plans because her plans
don't look like they're gonna work she
released her her health care plan was a
fifty two trillion dollar plan she had
no idea how she was going to pay for it
actually in some ways there's a parallel
to Trump 2016 here which is that
Elizabeth Warren now is trying to learn
the language of this radical left to to
get the nomination in the same way that
President Trump was of learning the
language of move
conservatism he was learning the
language of the people who have been
steeped in conservative politics for 20
years
Trump hadn't been Trump was a reality TV
show host he was a back casino mogul he
was a real estate mogul he just hadn't
dedicated his life to politics so he
wasn't as fluent in that language
Elizabeth Warren has been in politics a
long time she has much less of an excuse
and so as her campaign is collapsing as
Bernie is surging unexpectedly for many
people
Warren is using the last refuge of a
scoundrel she's accusing him of bigotry
and sexism or chauvinism or misogyny or
whatever this will certainly come up in
the debate tonight that's the whole
reason Elizabeth Warren leaked it in the
first place
we need to leave the realm of mainstream
identity politics for a while though and
take a look at the fringes of identity
politics because that is where you see
the future if you had said four years
ago five years ago that we would have
huge national debates over whether a man
can become a woman whether ever a man
should use the women's locker room or
the women's bathroom over whether we
should pay for male prisoners to to
mutilate their body become more
resembling of females if you had told us
this would be a national debate pronouns
you would have to tell people your
pronouns in your little email signature
or when you meet them we would have
laughed in your face that was such a
fringe ridiculous idea now it's
mainstream we're gonna take a look at
another fringe idea and see the logical
end of identity politics then we will
get to a wonderful little piece of
leftist hypocrisy on the environment the
left is trying to brush this under the
rug brush this under the glacier because
one of their big climate change
predictions has not come true we will
get to that we'll get to a whole lot
more but first I've got to say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube head on over to
daily wire.com ten bucks
no it's more we've raised our prices so
you got oh you got to pay attention to
some discounts that come around but
whatever the price is I don't have it
off the top of my head you get me you
get the andrew Clavin show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get the
I'll show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag coming up on Thursday you
get another Kingdom the final season we
just finished recording the final
episode of the final season yesterday
it's really really a beautiful piece
written by Andrew flavin check that out
and you get the Cory Booker tumbler
Estus it Watson is inacceptable a donde
esta la biblioteca oh wow it's like the
leftist tears from Cory Booker are
giving me the supernatural ability to
speak very very poor Spanish go on over
to Daly wire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
a convicted pedophile in Michigan is
going to prison for 10 to 20 years why
because he was caught with kiddie porn
on his computer this happens often in
this country you see this there's a seam
like there's a story like this every
week what makes this case different
however is the defense that this forty
five-year-old pedophile offered to the
judge and his defense was this it was
not illegal for him to have child
pornography on his computer he has a
right to have child pornography on his
computer because he has always been an 8
year old girl now I know that he's a 45
year old man but he says that actually
he has always been a 45 year old girl
and and the the language he uses is
pretty powerful he says in my fantasies
I have always been an eight-year-old
girl he said there are adults on the
internet who have sex with me as an
eight-year-old girl very confusing what
does that mean that means that he the
claim he is making is that his fantasies
are reality he's admitting it I mean we
say that all the time we say just
because you you're a man who thinks that
you're a woman in your fantasies doesn't
mean you actually are a woman they say
it's not a fantasy or in the case of
like Rachel Dolezal speaking of identity
politics just because you're a white
woman who in your fantasies as a black
woman doesn't mean you actually are a
black woman well this guy is admitting
he's saying in my fantasies I'm an
eight-year-old girl and my fantasies are
reality therefore I am an eight-year-old
girl and then he says there are adults
who have sex with me on the Internet as
as I am an 8 year old girl now you can't
have sex on the Internet you have to
have sex in person that's what sex is
there's a layer that's so insidious here
and it actually gets back into that
child but not the child porn debate
there's not much of debate on that but
onto the overall online pornography
debate which is the blurred line between
fantasy and reality if you go on from
the internet you look at all sorts of
disgusting horrible misogynistic
terrible things and you do that for an
hour a day let's say you do it for more
than an hour a day maybe it let's I mean
there's something I've read about cases
of people where it's become a total
absorbing addiction they don't go to
work anymore they can't get out of bed
in the morning they're just it's like
any drug that they would be addicted to
well if you spend that much time doing
this thing watching exploitation
watching perverse acts that's you that's
your life that's what you're doing you
are you are known by your actions right
you are known by how you spend your time
you are known by where you put your
resources one of which is your time and
your desire and your affection where
where a man puts his treasure that's
where his heart is also you can't have
sex on the internet but what he is
saying is because I engage in these
fantasies via I don't know I assume
they're typing it out because I engage
in these fantasies with people across
the internet I am really having sex with
them no you're not it's all virtual it's
all digital it's all fantasy this guy in
a virtual fantasy might be an
eight-year-old girl but in reality he's
not he's a guy who is trafficking in it
the exploitation of children and that's
the reality of it and I suspect that
what he tells himself every day is that
he's not really doing that I suspect
he's believing his own lies and I fear
that we as a society are believing our
own lies when it comes to not just porn
or something but even to this the the
identity politics question there are a
lot of people in this country who
believe this is the most exploitive
terrible oppressive country that's ever
existed in the world Stalin Mao Hitler
they ain't got nothing on us
we're so terrible we're so awful we're
so oppressed of course we're the richest
freest most just most equitable safest
society that has ever existed
no matter that's the reality that's not
the fantasy and the fantasy is
increasingly where people are living
look no further than Jessica Yaniv
Jessica Yaniv is a man who identifies as
a woman he's the guy who went up in
Canada and forced immigrant women at
beauty salons to wax his genitals he
went in to get a Brazilian wax just a
cosmetic procedure for women but he's
not a woman he's a man and they said
we're not going to do that we're not
going to touch your genitals but but
also the procedure for women is
different than for men the Brazilian wax
is different than the man zillion wax
because men and women are different this
guy was so upset he puts the women out
of business starts filing all of these
civil rights complaints he's a guy who
sent lewd text messages to an underage
girl speaking of our last story he's a
guy who just this year tried to host a
topless LGBT youth pool party for little
young teenagers now this guy is
physically assaulting people on the
street there was a journalist who is
covering one of his courtroom
appearances and this guy Jessica Yaniv
very very ladylike goes over and starts
punching the reporter pleading guilty
get away from me go away I'm crazy get
away get up go away from me stay away
from me get away from me now right now
you hurt me on the police on you I don't
give us get away from me you stay away
from me all right this guy obviously has
done some pretty bad things this guy
putting poor women out of business and
sending lewd messages to underage girls
and trying to lure kids into this awful
party and beating up journalists saying
this guy's done some awful things I
actually have some sympathy for him
though I actually feel bad for the guy
because
I think it's pretty clear he's not all
there in the head think it's pretty
clear he's got some issues that he's
working out he's got some problems five
years ago this would have been so
obvious we would have all said oh this
is a crazy person we need to get him
psychiatric help
everything he does which he does
constantly he's doing like every month
this guy is in the international news is
insane we should get him some help we
can't do that in this culture because in
this culture we are elevating fantasy
and delusion over reality and we are
saying that your own subjective
experience whatever you want the world
to be is the way the world really is
Justice Kennedy in the Planned
Parenthood v Casey decision says people
have a right to define their own reality
and of course they don't none of us has
a right to define reality not a single
one of us reality is what it is
and it's up to us to recognize that mm
to orient our lives to be in a
relationship with reality in a culture
driven crazy by identity politics we
need to pretend that Jessica you Nev is
normal and sure we'd haul them to court
and we say way you shouldn't send those
texts to those underage girls with the
pictures and stuff hey you shouldn't put
those immigrant women out of business
hey you shouldn't assault journalists
but overall we need to pretend that
everything else is fine in this guy's
life trying to completely redefine
reality that's totally fine it's just
that you threw a punch at that
independent journalist no the problem is
the fantasy the problem is indulging
people because we think that lies can be
comforting I mean that's what what is at
the bottom of all of this I gave a
speech on it during my my-y a lecture
tour last semester at the bottom of this
is this lie that the truth is cruel and
that lies are comforting that it's cruel
to say to Jessica you need you're a man
who has issues and you need some help
and that that it's comforting
say no Jessica you're really a woman no
pedophile in Michigan you're really an
eight-year-old girl no rachel dolezal
you're really a black woman even though
you're a white woman no very very
wealthy glamorous people in Hollywood
you're really oppressed all of you
regardless of your skin color in your
sex you're so oppressed no Democratic
candidates you're so present no you're
not you're not
there's nothing comforting about that
there's a great image on the Bayeux
Tapestry
which is an image of the Battle of
Hastings Rises a thousand-year-old
battle and in it there's a picture of
Bishop odo bishops were not allowed to
fight in the battles right they were
their clergy they're not allowed to
actually hold a sword and start chopping
people to bits
but Bishop odo was there in the battle
to prevent his men from retreating to
prevent them from running away and he
had a club and the image on the Bayeux
Tapestry is Bishop odo smacking these
young guys all over the head right and
the the line on it is here
Bishop odo wielding a club comforts the
boys comforts that's not what you and I
would think of as comforting to be
smacked on the head with a club but
sometimes that's what comforting means
because to comfort is to give strength
and when you're in the heat of battle
giving strength might mean a little flak
with the club when you're in the heat of
political crisis comfort might mean
telling people truths that they
ironically call uncomfortable but
they're not the only thing uncomfortable
in the long run is lies speaking of
which really being leftist lie for years
now at Montana's Glacier National Park
there have been signs at the glaciers
which say these glaciers will be gone by
2020 because that's always the way it is
right al gore told us that New York and
Florida we're gonna be underwater by
what 2013 something like that we were
told in the 60s that overpopulation was
going to destroy the whole world that
there'd be mass starvation 100 million
people dying a year now between 1970 and
today the world population has doubled
people have never been fatter people
have never been better fed poverty has
never been lower so they have these
signs they say that the glaciers be gone
by 2020
well 2020 is here the glaciers are still
there all the glaciers is still there 29
glaciers still they're not melted it all
by climate change so they're trying to
take the signs down one by one we should
not let them do that if anybody in the
White House is listening President Trump
if you are listening
the president has control over the
national parks you got to make sure that
those signs stay up and if they've been
taken down put them back up the way that
the left gets away with these constant
lies this constant crisis everything's a
crisis it's urgent
give us everything we want or the world
is going to end that's what the most
prominent voice is on climate change are
telling us and have been for 40 years
the way they get away with it is we let
them take down the signs we let them
rewrite history
we let them rewrite their own statements
so that the Armageddon is always going
to be the day after tomorrow give us
what we want today otherwise tomorrow
the whole world is gonna fall apart
keep those signs up we need a national
movement to keep those signs up and let
their hypocrisy let their lies let their
let their wild and untrue predictions
their hysteria be put on full display we
got some pretty good news we got to end
on a good note because we've got the
left crumbling we got the left falling
apart and we've got Hollywood falling
apart and we got the right growing and
growing Trump's numbers doing very very
well
impeachment totally helped him killing
sulemani totally helped him World War
three definitely helped him he was World
War three lasted about 15 minutes and we
want it pretty clearly we wanted more
decisively than we won the last world
war so President Trump was going to a
football game it was the Louisiana
Clemson game and you see all these
videos over the past few months of Trump
at a sports event and he gets booed
those are the ones that go on CNN those
are the ones that go on MSNBC he didn't
get booed at this event he acts
we got raucous applause and a standing
ovation here's the president from
Louisiana State University and Clemson
University joined by the President of
the United States and the first lady
there is very popular in lots of
different areas of America you won't see
that on the mainstream media though and
and I think that's why they're always so
surprised when the Democratic candidates
don't do well when people don't tune in
to the Oscars
when President Trump wins in 2016 there
so surprised because we've never seen
anybody applaud Trump as as New York
Times reporters were saying in the 70s I
don't know anybody who voted for Richard
Nixon except he keeps winning in a
landslide and on that point I encourage
you to check out the dumbest article on
the internet today from the LA Times so
it's written by Virginia Heffernan the
column is titled coal trumpism what it
is a cult the article begins the
comparisons have come hard and fast at
least since 2015 Trump is like Silvio
Berlusconi
like Adolf Hitler like Boris Johnson
it's time to stop searching for the
exact analogy for Trump what demands
analysis is less the arrogance 73
year-old mediocrity in the Oval Office
but the Worshipful attitude so many
americans have toward him a lot of nut
jobs have peddled wise to Americans
before even styled themselves as
messianic but at no time in history have
so many Americans been drawn to what
looks increasingly like a cult I don't
use the term recklessly but you can
imagine I won't read the rest of it but
Pretty Reckless then it just quotes a
bunch of Democrats talking about how
much they hate Trump nowhere in the
article as far as I can tell is any fact
about the Trump presidency nowhere is
any mention of a booming economy or the
relative peace abroad were the killing
of the two biggest arists on the face of
the earth Baghdady and sulemani
or the 401ks going up or the record low
unemployment or the record deregulation
or wages rising for the first time in 10
years or and none of that is here all we
hear is mind control and brainwashing
and how much they hate Trump and now
he's terrible and how it's a cult what
are what are cults
cults are religious or quasi religious
movements where people abandon their
senses abandon their reason and follow
people who are demagogues who follow
people who have some kind of irrational
or emotional control over them that is
not what's happening in the Trump
movement the Trump movement in 2016 for
a great many people the argument for
voting for Trump is that he would
certainly be better than Hillary
even if he were terrible he would almost
certainly be better than Hillary since
then we've got data points we've got
facts which are totally missing from
these diatribes against the president
which are totally missing from the
Democratic presidential debates which
are totally missing from the hysteria on
the left on the internet and elsewhere
we've got the facts the numbers are in
to vote for Trump to support Trump to
support conservatives is a pretty
rational act if you like a good economy
like relative peace abroad you like all
those judges we're interpreting our
Constitution as it was written if you
like all that stuff if you don't like
all the crazy divisiveness then you
support the president you support the
conservative or on the Left if you think
that America is the most racist bigoted
awful terrible dangerous place that
there ever was and you believe that the
world is going to end tomorrow because
the glaciers melted in 2020 because
climate change is gonna kill us all and
you believe that a man is a woman and
you you believe trust me it'll happen
and I don't know two or three years that
people can identify as different ages
and their forty-five year old man can be
an eight-year-old girl if you believe
all that kind of stuff then you probably
prefer the left which one of those is
the cult pretty clear to me
that's her show I'm Michael nose this is
the Michael Nolt show come back tomorrow
see them la situación our water is
inacceptable
yes babe Presidente at Aqaba
Damona da de los immigrant aces
inacceptable a voyeur can be arrested
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]